what is your favorite word think about
it for a moment think real hard write it
down in the comments posted for everyone
else to see how many letters does it
have how many syllables say it aloud how
does it sound how does it feel on your
tongue really
really think about it now make sure you
keep that word in mind it's important
and we'll come back to it later for now
it's time to talk about scp-3449
look there's really nothing any special
about this one it wasn't even important
enough to be mentioned with the other
info hazards it's not an evil talking
toaster that's for sure
scp-3449 appears to just be a standard
spiral not book not book it's supposed
to be notebook right anyway it's just a
standard spiral notebook with a dark
blue cover it's safe class and it's
stored in the stand red
standard containment locker in site 19.
there aren't any other containment
requires but testing is currently
underway to determine um i think it's
meant to be determined long-term
containment requirements ah this is a
mess
anyway this item and its anomalous power
is actually considered so
inconsequential that researchers have
explored the possibility of putting it
on the anomalous item's log a place
where items too useless to warrant to
full file ends up geez how do you
misspell up that badly it's two letters
well it's supposed to be two letters how
did you work z into that they aren't
even close to each other in keyboard
man
anyway the notebook contains mostly
blank pages some are torn and only six
contain actual writing but due to the
formatting of the ridding the text
consisting mainly of diary entries is
almost unreadable this is due to
synaptical errors random capitalization
and rampant imp mis spellings great you
misspelled misspellings
how cute apparently all attempts to
correct these misspellings fail or even
lead to additional misspellings this
anomalous effect extends to anyone
attempting to write yep that was spelled
r-i-g-h-t
attempting to write about scp-3449
including the script for this video
apparently there are no further notable
anonymous properties tests are ongoing
though those with any inquiries about
testing
scp-3449 should contact lead researcher
nichola gerdnell the knotbock which was
misspelled even worse this time
impressive was first recovered by mtf
epsilon vi also known as the village
idiots after a series of info-hazardous
and cognito hazardous phenomenon were
discovered in the pittsburgh metroid
area the source seemed to be a storage
unit filled with anomalous items and
scp-3449 was a mogus i think that's
meant to be among
them the storage unit was registered to
a man by the name of edward salsborough
currently designated as porpoise of
interest 4335.
that's the end of that thanks for
watching the video folks now go check
out oh
wait there's more phenomenal let's keep
going apparently that version of the
file was an older one let's check the
next one and see if that's any more
useful oh oh oh my it appears that the
updates here are actually quite
extensive
okay let's give this another try
scp-3449 is a euclid-class spc kept in
the humanid containment cells of site
19. items affected by it are kept in
standard storage lockers for safe class
anomalous objects at the same site the
primary reason for this shift is that
scp-3449 has changed its object of
designation it is no longer the spiral
notebook it is now a 34-year-old
caucasian man known as edward sellsboro
formerly known as person of interest
4335
he is believed to be the creator of the
knotbock as well as other objects found
in the storage looker in pittsburgh
foundation personnel are now trying to
locate and contain any other objects
created by mr selzberg though success
has been limited on this front that was
cute
scp-3449's analogous abilities manifest
onto both edward himself and all the
objects created by him ridding about him
or any of these objects will result in
synaptical
errors arbitrary capitalizations
and rampart imp
smellings attempts to revise or correct
the writing will either fail to remove
the errors or create new errors it
appears that the anomaloninous effects
of
scp-3449 proper are more severe than
that of the ones caused by his anomalous
objects mtf epsilon 6 also known as the
village idiots apprehended as cp 3449 in
his apartment just outside of pritzberg
he appeared to be in an advanced state
of disorientation
and dehydration records collected by the
mobile task force found that mr selberg
had not left his apprattment in over 10
days which would account for his dire
health conditions salzburg did not
communicate with mambas of the mobile
task force but did not reset arrest and
subsequent containment either
okay okay these spellings are rough but
i'm going to try and power through i am
a professional and we're almost there
the following is the full lug of items
obtained from
scp-3449 storage look car that also
exhibit his anomalous effects the
notebook as already discussed the pages
are either blank torn or illegible
salzburg's computer files saved on this
device include
dealing personal finances ideals for
products and an unfinished horror novel
that is almost unraidable due to the
poor quality of its writing grocery list
had only two written items booter was
spelled with only one tea and medication
which was spelled medic caschon a
planner last entry was dated two weeks
before containment and believed to
contain reminders to perform various
chores however a mixture of poor
handwriting and word choice allows for
other interpretations and finally mr
salzberg's cell phone foundation
researchers were also able to collect
the call logs in hopes of further
tracking salzburg's pre-containment
activities the last three calls which
were all made on the same day two weeks
before contentment dialed different
numbers only one of which was in use the
foundation made contact with the
receiver of said call who had known
knowledge of scp-3449
and claimed that they did not answer the
call lead researcher nichola gerdinel
conduced the first in interview with
scp-3449 shortly after his capture when
he entered the interview chambri he
found that
scp-3449 was just sitting in the corner
which with his head in his hands rocking
back and forth in what appeared to be
apparent distress he then began looking
down into his lap and twiddling his
thumbs like a child nicolo engaged him
in a calm and polite tone addressing him
as scp-3449
the animali made eye contact with dr
gerdnell but he didn't respond and
instead continues starring at him as
gerdanel axed further quest tunes
salzburg simply didn't answer or would
at the very most acknowledge the
questions with simple gestures gerdnell
asked whether salzburg was making
products for his business to which he
smiled and shook his head gerdnell then
asked selzberg whether he could speak or
not or if it was merely a choose on his
part unsurprisingly salzburg offered no
explanation and the interview came to a
close shortly afterwards tests are still
ongoing to find out if salzburg's
inability to spack or communicate come
as a result of his anomalous traits or
if this is simply a result of apiphonia
a uncommon but non-anomalous condition
that renders its victims unable to spike
tests have confirmed that salzburg does
have all the organs required for
vocalization but suppears to not use
them further tests are required alright
there we have it that was a complete
nightmare to read thanks to
scp-3449's anomalous effects but at
least it's over now
now go check out wait there's more
another update to the file good okay
[Music]
all right let's go take a look oh i see
this is a lot more dangerous than i
thought i suppose i better read on
scp-3449 has been upgraded to ketter
class enamel scp-3449-a
the new designation for edward
salzburger is to be kept in a security
hazmat content maintenance in site 19.
the inanimate anomalous possessions of
edward salzburg are to be keeped in
standard object containment any reports
written on
scp-3449 must be rotten by popple who
have been exposed to it for less than
seven days in order to keep the files
raidable to prevent this infectious
infohezmard from spread further the
number of people allowed to interact
with this anomaly is kept relatively
small and consists of those that have
already been exposed at some point or
another this includes
05-8 mtf epsilon 6 dr teller's research
team some additional personnel selected
for
xpc-3449 research and personnel chosen
to update
scp-3449 documentation some additional
personnel selected for xpc 3449 research
and personnel chosen to update
scp-3449 documentation while edward
selzberg and his personal effects are
cranially locked up
scp-3449 is not currently considered
contained research into the sprod of
scp-3449's effects the vectors for
transmission and any potential
recremities for its degenerative effects
are now tope priority for all in loved
before this whole ting gets out of hand
further research has taught the
foundation that not only are salzburg
and his items powerful info hazards
their anomalous effects appear to be
able to infect these who experience them
permanently initially it will a prayer
that writing quality only degrades when
the subject is actually writing about
scp-3449
itself but over time they'll come to the
frightening realization that it actually
affects their rifting as a whole the
effect also progresses in its semerity
over time eventually rendering the
victim's ability to write legible
sentences completely disployed the
initial anomalous effects of
scp-3449 were discovered when mtf
epsilon 6 writes their field reports on
the mater and found it littered with
synaptical error random capitalism show
and rampant implies similar errors
appearing in the initial fail about
scp-3449 only serve to reaffirm this
observation however researcher only
began to notice true extent of
scp-3449's effects when the village
idiots field reports concerning other
solomonies came in with equally
atrocious writing attempts to correct
this writing simply led
to more mistakes and frustration on part
of team soon after a restretcher named
dr teller who'd since trek and ove wrote
the scp-3449
case and his team found that they were
experienced similar issues they couldn't
just make the blurreds happen no matter
how hard they constrained they forgot
spellings they couldn't make hand move
in the manner they waited to in order to
form the wards even the most intelligent
and articulate members of the team came
across as extremely young children on
page but didn't stop there wasn't long
before researchers who'd never worked on
the scp-3449k
started to exhaust these same suspicious
errors in own writing the foundation
didn't know how but this little likeness
was starting to spread with people's
abilities to write degrading across the
entire foundation that's when a
foundation web trawler picked up
something even more distraught global
literacy seemed to be taking a dive the
telltale synaptical error random to
capitalization and rampant illinois
spillings ticking up everywhere and for
everyone and the end of writing would be
one thing but
scp-3449 doesn't stop there no that's
just the begrinning morse code go next
then pictograms not long for sign
language become hopeless scrambled
communication
breaks down little by little people
can't draw anymore can't move
right hands
goal goes calls codes last go his voice
talking gets
hard remember favorite
word
think about it say it loud
when scp-3449
done when everyone infected you'll never
say again nobody will ever say
now go check out minecraft world
destroyer
scp-4335 a welt in the crucible and
scp-055 anti-meme unknown for more
mind-bending anomalies from the scp
foundation